Google cloud next 2017 hosted an almost
disturbingly large number of talks
detailing the future of cloud if you
didn't get a chance to catch the session
called stackdriver
monitor debug fix then stay tuned
because here's the recap stack driver is
a sass package for monitoring logging
and diagnostics that help you gain
insight into applications that run on
Google cloud platform and Amazon Web
Services one big advantage of stack
driver is not having to bounce between
several different websites to look at
your error roundup aggregated logs and
application performance monitoring to
understand more about how to use this
great tool let's take a deeper look at
monitor every application needs some
sort of monitoring and nearly every
application means some sort of uptime
check after that we want to monitor
things that are actionable for you a
good monitor for web app is the response
code ratios if I'm getting a certain
number of 400 or 500 responses that's a
problem I want to be aware of you also
want to monitor your database to make
sure it's keeping up one of the cool
things about stack driver monitoring is
that it can detect what you're likely
running on your VM and support several
common third-party tools including my
sequel Apache Cassandra CouchDB MongoDB
Postgres and many many more for
supported services the stack driver
monitoring agent will discover what
you're running even if you haven't
configured the server specific plugin it
does this by examining instance names
and looking for specific ports being
opened in firewall rules if it finds a
supported third-party tool it will
populate it in the resources list to
include that service there's also
metrics supported for many Google
services for example you can monitor the
number of interceptions that the App
Engine does to prevent gos attacks or
the number of operations happening in a
firebase database and the uploaded bytes
per minute to bigquery and finally most
production apps need some sort of crash
or error reporting and alerting stack
driver has an error reporting tool
built-in so you can subscribe to alerts
and get notified about new crashes with
automatic throttle back so you aren't
getting nagged over and over if
everything is going horribly wrong
there are several alerting methods
available including slack HipChat
pager SMS email and the app and you can
include a custom message with the alert
perhaps explaining what debug
steps to take if the alert is triggered
once you get an alert you can dig into
it using stackdriver
error reporting here is the error
reporting dashboard showing some crashes
you can drill down to see how many times
this error has happened and for App
Engine apps which versioned it first
happened in and which version it last
happened in like monitoring and the
error analysis works in a hybrid cloud
environment there are language specific
libraries for the seven main Google
Cloud languages if you wish to send your
own crash reports to error reporting and
if you set up stack driver logging you
get their reporting looking a bit deeper
this error you can see the stack trace
which offers an idea of where something
may have gone wrong the log lets us see
more information about the error like
the request parameters in the HTTP
response code using the stack driver
debugger you can figure out what the
application state is at that point the
divider lets you get a snapshot of the
application state at a given point
during execution the runtime debugger
currently supports Java Python and go
applications running on App Engine or
compute engine now if you want to see
stackdriver in action with a series of
Awesome demos check out the full video
on YouTube and if you want more recaps
on great next content make sure to check
out the rest of our playlist and don't
forget the Google cloud summit coming
soon to a city near you
[Music]
you